all her life Rebecca Kiwanuka has cooked
with chuckle but it's both bad for her
help and bad for the environment it is
also expensive now she has a special new
stove it costs a lot but it can still
save her money I used to use a lot of
choco I calculated each year I was using
choco worth 1.2 million shillings in
this home for one year but now that the
chocolate choco Dustin used doesn't go
even beyond at 100 thousand volcanic
rock is the key to this new eco stove
once the rocks are heated they remain
hot for hours with the help of a
solar-powered fan that blows a
continuous flow of air over them the Eco
stove was invented by Ross twine she
runs the company that makes them we have
a technology that can reduce more than
90 percent of the tree cutting in Uganda
because with the cost of reusing
volcanic rocks which are burning more
than choco burns more than fire wood
burns it's clean it's efficient
it's neat the volcanic rocks can be used
for about two years an average the Eco
stove comes in various configurations
including large commercial ones like
this range at a market in the capital
Kampala where a thousand people come to
eat every day it's also beneficial for
the cooks who use it because the device
generates almost no smoke estimates a
smoke from traditional stoves contribute
to the death of almost twenty thousand
people a year in Uganda the new stove is
also more efficient than conventional
designs you can cook anything on these
stoves and save a lot the stoves have
really helped us because after building
them here the company gives you the
volcanic rocks
Amanda we have since given up using
charcoal and only use charcoal dust
which we use to light the rocks I now
just spend a quarter of the money I used
to spend on charcoal tabanga-do Motoyasu
in south western Uganda at the foot of
Mount maja Bora eco stove has provided
me opportunities for farming families
it has trained and employed a number of
groups to extract the rods which are
later collected and taken to the company
premises when a truck comes I get up to
$100 I can use the money to pay school
fees for my children buy them clothes
and food life is much better now because
people buy these rocks we used to grow
crops and the stones got in the way of
that but now we're lucky enough to have
someone pay for them there is a large
toe of volcanic rocks at the Eco stove
Factory the company builds up to 40
stoves a day around 17,000 have been
sold so far each comes with a small bug
a box
Rose chain says the device could be used
in many regions and countries we want to
scale as many people to become
intrapreneurs to be able to do exactly
what we're doing in various parts of the
country we don't want to own the
technology and who remains here Uganda
has a population of 40 million 90% still
cuckoo chuckle so there is a huge
potential market for the Eco stove the
benefits will also be huge and help to
slow that forestation of the African
continent